quand vous vous regardez le matin dans
le miroir vous vous dites quoi
toujours aussi belle gracieuse
mystérieuse Fellini a dit le temps se
comporte avec toi comme un gentleman
il avait raison il a dit ça
alors avant de parler de vous on va
parler d'un prix dont vous êtes
présidente d'honneur c'est le prix ciné
roman Carte Noire ça a pris assez utile
parce que ça permet chaque année de un
livre d'être adapté au cinéma c'est une
espèce de pont entre le cinéma et la
littérature c'est un prix qui a été créé
par Arlette Gordon et Patrick Debourg
et ils m'ont dit j'étais président ta
vie je dis fais attention parce que je
vais vivre très longtemps
mais cette année c'était Nicole Garcia
qui était là présidente et je suis
formidable c'est une idée formidable
jardin un livre magnifique de Michel
quin qui a été adapté par Jean Becker au
cinéma et cette année ces plateformes de
Michel Houellebecq qui risque donc
d'être adapté au cinéma voilà et puis
alors vous avez reçu aussi un César
d'honneur
[Applaudissements]
et bien merci je voulais savoir on peut
en avoir plusieurs des sésame
on en a 15 ces ordonnances
parce que
là je viens de Los Angeles ils m'ont dit
vous avez un César donnait it's life
activement
ça veut dire quoi la vie achevée ça m'a
pas beaucoup plu et ils m'ont dit mais
c'est pour votre carrière et alors là
j'ai pensé ça doit pas être pour ma
carrière parce que j'ai jamais vraiment
fait une carrière je me sens pas du tout
comme ça et c'est drôle parce que
d'ailleurs j'avais l'intention de
commencer une carrière maintenant
n'est-ce pas Dominique j'y compte parce
que j'ai jamais j'ai jamais fait rien
pour mais je crois que je avec le temps
qu'il me reste j'aimerais bien commencer
[Applaudissements]
du film
bravo alors on va voir comment tout ça a
commencé
[Applaudissements]
donc kanuki c'est pas votre vrai nom on
s'en serait douté quand même
[Applaudissements]
non votre prénom c'est Françoise Judith
Dreyfus mais effectivement vous êtes
appelés à nos quémé tellement jeune que
vous êtes un petit peu devenu elle à
force non on est 13 ans et demi alors
ça va 69 vous savez que c'était à vous
de me poser une question Anouk il faut
que je pose une question
[Musique]
et très difficile ma question je
voudrais savoir non enfin dire demander
surtout je voudrais savoir comment vous
arrivez en posant des questions à tous
les gens qui posaient ces questions
de respecter leurs réponses tout en
restant vous-même parce qu'on ressent
exactement ce que vous ressentez quand
il donne la réponse et ça j'admire
beaucoup ça de vous et je me demande
comment il arrive à faire ça
je suis incapable de vous répondre je
prends ça comme un compliment d'une
certaine façon mais non
je voulais te je voulais te poser
exactement la même question mais j'ai
pas réussi à la formuler
dans votre famille il y avait beaucoup
de pseudos déjà puisque votre père et
votre mère était comédien votre père se
faisait appeler Henri muret et votre
mère Geneviève Soria voilà et vous à
nous qu'en fait c'est le nom du
personnage de votre premier film la
maison sous la mer
c'est une idée de Jacques Prévert qui
vous a dit tu vas pas t'appeler à nous
que quand tu auras 40 ans ce qui
paraissait tellement vieux que j'y
pensais pas et il m'a trouvé aimer c'est
pour ça que je les avait dit en fait
mais il a dit non bon bref et j'étais
tellement flatté et enfin Prévert c'est
quelqu'un de tellement spécial
au début vous aviez pas une vraie
vocation de comédienne vous dites
pharmacienne ou danseuse classique
vous savez tout alors de toute façon
vos parents étaient comédiens puis il y
a eu la guerre aussi et l'occupation
nazie fallait se cacher vous êtes allé
chez vous chez vos grands-parents chez
votre parrain chez votre marraine on est
pensionnat c'est une soirée de
pensionnaire ce soir là
donc vous étiez à Marseille à Bandol à
Morzine et vous étiez au collège avec
Vadim c'est vrai j'étais à l'école et
Eva dit mais sa sœur était là c'est
d'ailleurs la dîme qui m'a appris à ce
qui est d'ailleurs
très séduisant je sais pas la première
fois que je l'ai vu c'était en salle
d'études comme il était quand même plus
grand que moi plus vieux que moi alors
nous mélanger moi j'étais toute seule et
il y avait il était très grand et il
était au bout de la salle il a fait
l'idiot pour que j'ai peur et j'ai
carrément eu peur je dis un idiot
il faisait complètement n'importe
comment c'est la première fois que j'ai
vu vas-y mais voilà c'était dur quand
même là-bas non vous dites qu'un jour
vous avez vu un résistant qui avait été
tué par les par les Allemands oui il
l'avait tué il était descendu de la
montagne juste devant notre chalet et
comme punition ils l'ont laissé pourrir
devant nous et tous les jours nous on
allait à l'école et fallait qu'on passe
à côté
et alors la libération vous êtes à
Marseille et vous voyez des soldats
allemands prisonniers qui défilent avec
les mains sur la tête les l'uniforme
maculé de sang et des fils sous les
crachats
on les attendait moi je me souviens que
ma mère m'a pris par la main on a couru
on est arrivé en haut de la Canebière et
là les Allemands tiraient toujours il y
avait personne et tout d'un coup je les
ai vu arriver et là c'était bon les
Américains les Anglais je sais pas ils
sont arrivés avec les tanks et les
soldats étaient de chaque côté ils
marchait lentement et pour moi ils
avaient 4 mètres de haut et c'était du
slow motion vous savez j'ai l'impression
que c'était des des extraterrestres
c'était pas des gens comme nous et ils
allaient lentement et tout les gens de
s'embrasser tout d'un coup j'ai vu les
le groupe de des premiers prisonniers
allemands et Jésus avec du sang les
masses sur la tête
déchirer et j'étais très surprise que ce
soit pas ça qui allait me rendre
heureuse que eux maintenant ils avaient
perdu eux ils étaient humiliés et ça je
suis 18 alors c'est pas ça vous avez une
très bonne nature
alors après il y a un miracle en 1946
vous promener avec votre famille sur les
Champs-Élysées il y a un monsieur qui
salue votre mère à hauteur de la rue du
Colisée et le soir vous êtes toujours
accompagné de votre maman quand même
vous allez au cinéma et là vous revoyez
le même monsieur
il demande à votre mère si vous pouvez
faire du cinéma ça arrive jamais ça dans
la vie moi ça m'est arrivé et ma mère a
dit tu as envie je dis oui et bon j'ai
dit oui c'est comme ça que j'ai fait mon
premier film qui était la maison sous la
mer avec Henri Calais réalisateur assez
important à l'époque alors après vous
prenez des cours quand même vous avez le
cours Bauer et vous faites la fleur de
l'âge donc avec carnet Prévert arlettir
Reggiani qui n'a jamais été terminée
manque d'argent manque d'argent c'est
une histoire de jeunes délinquants qui
se déroulaient à Belle-Île c'est ça et
là un jour vous devez embrasser un
garçon
il fallait que je l'embrasse et il avait
plein de boutons
parce que je m'approchais j'arrivais je
faisais je peux pas marcher le Cardi
c'est pas possible il y avait un long
avenue il fallait refaire le sable
refaire tout et on recommencer j'avais
si je peux pas il me dit mais c'est pas
possible et pourquoi je dis jamais
embrassé un garçon je veux pas que le
premier garçon est des boutons
voilà
ensuite vous faites les amandes vérones
donc avec kayak et toujours Reggiani
alors la pub c'était la première
Juliette qui a vraiment 15 ans voilà
donc c'était c'était un gros succès et
puis ça a été pour vous extrêmement
important ce film non ouais les amandes
Vérone donc Roméo et Juliette bien sûr
ensuite vous vivez un petit peu
l'aventure de Saint-Germain-des-Prés
vous êtes votre mari avait la rose rouge
donc c'est ça facilitait les choses un
cabaret rue de Rennes la rose rouge et
votre mari c'était Nico pas patakis
alors c'était un cabaret littéraire on a
plus trop l'habitude de ça maintenant
parce que c'est fini il y avait des
spectacles de Queneau de Cocteau de
plein de gens
c'était Sartre c'était Simone de
Beauvoir
le monde était à refaire et puis le
monde n'était pas violent en ce moment
moi je me souviens je pense maintenant
j'étais très jeune mais j'aurais pu
traverser Paris rentrer le soir toute
seule j'avais pas peur truc maintenant
on aurait peur même de vous engage pour
la dolce vita il m'a dit vous voudrez
faire ce rôle je dis oui mais je savais
qu'il avait demandé la même chose à 200
filles et il m'a regardé et il m'a dit
vous le ferez et il avait des yeux vous
savez
impressionnant qui vous transperçait
comme je dois dire j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer Picasso et j'avais eu la même
chose quand j'avais vu il avait des yeux
qui allaient à travers
le cinéma d'une certaine façon oui parce
qu'avant
je sais pas c'était il y avait une app
pudeur je trouvais que c'était impudique
je trouvais non mais Fellini m'a appris
d'abord la première chose c'est pas se
prendre au sérieux je crois que c'est
une chose très importante et à ce moment
là j'ai commencé à aimer ce que je
faisais parce que c'est une façon de
vivre de pour Fellini c'était une autre
façon de vivre alors après il y a Lola
de Jacques Demy que des films importants
vous faites quand même c'est assez là
c'est un classique
d'ailleurs demi vous impose contre la
vie des producteurs au départ les
producteurs vous trouvez pas assez sexy
et alors après quand demi a fait modèle
shop que tu es une espèce de suite
quelque part de Lola alors là il avait
découvert quelqu'un qu'il a pas réussi à
imposer au conducteur
il me dit quand j'arrive là-bas à Los
Angeles il me dit écoute j'ai trouvé un
jeune gars formidable il faut que tu
m'aides parce qu'ils n'en veulent pas et
c'était Harrison Ford et ils n'ont pas
voulu
c'est pas possible c'est
Colombia je le dis quand même bien et
puis après ben évidemment un homme une
femme palme d'or à Cannes Golden Globes
Hollywood et là vous êtes applaudi par
Fred Astaire par John Wayne par Henry
Fonda enfin tous les gens que vous
admiriez énormément il vous les voyez en
train de vous appeler dire comme ça
c'est
que je me suis mon dieu mais c'est eux
que j'aimais quand j'étais mot mais ils
sont là en train de m'applaudir là si
j'étais très impressionnée alors John
Wayne vous étiez tellement intello
française un peu de gauche John way il
avait fait la balade des béret vert il
était mal vu à l'époque français c'est
comme Clint Eastwood un moment qui me
disent il était traité de nazis dans
tous les journaux en France
et donc John Wayne vous refusait d'aller
le saluer c'est lui il voulait venir
c'est lui qui vient il vient aider je
sais que vous avez refusé de venir me
voir je me suis sentie mes petits idiote
mais je voulais simplement vous dire
mais là c'est un compliment je suis un
peu gênée de dire mais bon bref il me
dit il y a 30 ans j'ai vu les mêmes yeux
ici c'était ce John Crawford et je
voulais vous souhaiter bonne chance j'ai
eu l'air d'une idiote j'avais honte
alors Hollywood organise une partie pour
vous et là vous demandez d'avoir mais
ouest et gros chômage seulement vous
avez-vous chômage vous savez en Amérique
quand vous arrivez que ça va bien ils
veulent tout vous donner tout ce que
vous voulez qu'est-ce que vous fait
plaisir vous voulez rencontrer un tel un
tel ça me gênait déjà l'idée de demander
à quelqu'un voulait la rencontrer alors
Isa assistaient je dis moi alors je
voudrais mes West mais mais ouais je
pouvais pas venir j'ai dit bon courage
et il est venu et il a dit mais qui sait
cette
comment dire en anglais qui veut me voir
plus personne veut me voir il est arrivé
moi j'étais ému et un moment il a mis
son cigare et moi j'ai piqué son cigare
c'est merveilleux non
de temps en temps
[Rires]
et puis ensuite vous réalisez que vous
travaillez depuis de longues années vous
décidez de poser les valises et vous
avez envie d'être femme au foyer ça
c'est énorme
femme au foyer pas avec n'importe qui
avec albertinet quand même donc c'est
bien et là vous installez à Londres vous
apprenez à faire la cuisine j'aurais
aimé voir ça mais vous savez tout
incroyable
en fait toute façon en Angleterre
récemment alors vous avez un film qui
est sorti aux Etats-Unis qui s'appelle
festival in Cannes d'Henri Jacques Lomme
avec les taskakis
aux États-Unis maintenant je dois dire
qu'on a eu des critiques formidables
c'est la paramoune classe qui l'a pris
et je crois que là ça ira à Cannes pas
en tant que compétition mais invité
comme ça enfin même en dehors du
festival juste puisque ça a été tourné
là-bas festival in Cannes ça s'appelle
voilà alors le problème avec vous si
vous avez fait des films donc la dolce
vita 8 et demi un homme une femme il est
toujours resté extrêmement marginal
pourquoi ça a toujours en dehors
toujours je sais pas peut-être que
naturellement je me protège assez
les choses comme vous avez dit tout à
l'heure sont toujours venues vers moi
c'est vrai peut-être que maintenant elle
vienne moi je sais pas mais j'ai jamais
été je me suis jamais battue j'ai
toujours laissé les choses venir c'est
peut-être un tort c'est pas bien
je vous remercie je viens que chez vous
c'est ma soirée moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va faire une heure divio
à la bouche par pendant le jingle
c'est bien vous êtes figés
[Musique]
quand vous vous regardez le matin dans
le miroir vous dites quoi
je me regarde mais je mets pas mes
lunettes comme ça ça va
quand avez-vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois j'ai pleuré il y a pas tellement
longtemps j'ai vu un programme je crois
sur Arte sur des enfants palestiniens et
israéliens il y a deux mois moi je sais
pas et
qui est évidemment là où ils étaient et
ils ont passé une journée tous ensemble
et ils ont joué comme des mots mais
après ils sont rentrés chez eux et après
les gosses sont dit c'est terrible quand
on sera grand on va peut-être se tuer ça
ça m'a complètement
ils étaient pareils et ça m'a bouleversé
je dois dire si la vie était à refaire
peut-être que je serais consciente
malheureusement que l'argent a quand
même une certaine importance jamais fait
attention à l'argent faut quand même un
petit peu faire attention peut-être
sinon j'ai pas trop à me plaindre
si vous restez 24 heures à vivre feriez
quoi pendant ces 24 heures non je pars
tout de suite à honoli parce que je
gagne un jour
qu'est-ce que la vie vous a appris
la tolérance
j'ai posé la question chancelle pour
finir c'est traditionnel et Dieu dans
tout ça
je crois qu'en ce moment il doit être
parti en vacances
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu